and that's what i think is happening
right now with nft land people are
buying the newest mint the newest mint
the newest bad the newest influencer
pump
and what you're looking for is the 4 to
5 to 15 to 75 really good projects i
believe the only way you even have a
prayer is to make a judgment call on the
founder
all right gary first off thank you so
much for doing this it's monday night at
uh 7 p.m
i uh so i appreciate you jumping on to
record a podcast with me thanks for
being
it my here so i got a bunch of questions
right i think one of the most obvious
things is like people
have heard about nfcs for a long period
of time and most people it takes some
period of time before they actually get
it before it clicks in their mind what
was that for you was it the community
was it just the the fact that you could
now own something on the internet
digitally like what clicked in your mind
where you said holy [ __ ] this could be
huge
that i believe that people communicate
through what they buy more than anything
humans do on earth
and that once i understood
the complexities but actually the lack
of friction
with my anticipation
that
the tech infrastructure was going to get
simpler by the day
that coinbase had gone public you know i
think a lot of people are confused that
it takes 67 ingredients for something to
pop off
that sports cards
had had exploded in the last three years
that
the robin hood crowd was and reddit
crowd was grooming and yet youngsters
thinking of themselves as investors as
popular culture
that the world of
roblox and fortnite
and
2k and madden points that digital
currency
candy crush
these things
mobile games where you power up for
digital you know that that was happening
that social media had hit a crescendo
where
you're
taking photos constantly to communicate
to people oftentimes alluding to things
that you spent money on whether that's
food wine
a trip the way you travel clothes
i just had put in enough work in a
concentrated period of time where i
realized oh people going to buy these
things because they're going to want to
communicate with their friends and then
once i understand the utility of the
contract if you look at be friends which
launches four months later it's attached
to a three-year physical conference you
know
six months later i opened a restaurant
that the membership is right so
it was not only the social behavior that
i have watched humans do from the
history of time and here's a new outlet
at scale
and they're going to be able to use the
social web 2
mature world to flex their web three
assets
oh and by the way there's a secondary
non-trivial part which is
this isn't about communication
and human behavior this is about utility
contracts
oh there seems to be enough smoke around
this
um
my spidey senses are like we're getting
close let me go in deep and this is
gonna pop off sometime in the next year
or two
i feel like it happened six months later
this summer right um and so
that's kind of why
from day one i wanted to strategize
access and events with b friends because
i know when the [ __ ] hits the fan if i
just decide i don't like what's going on
even though my contract currently
obligates me to three v cons
if i want to just add three because the
market's [ __ ] and i feel bad for people
that spend 30k to buy one and now the
current market's eight well i can do
that
it's my huge preference not to
these things cost 10 million dollars a
piece to throw i don't have a lot of
time i'd like to like do other things
but if i want to
if i want to
because
40 of my holders bought at the height of
the market and i feel like i want to
oh my god i can and that's very
different once i understood that power
and i knew myself which was i will never
compromise my reputation for money
this is built for me
that's why joe i went full steam because
i knew that i could protect myself by
always providing value to the original
holders in perpetuity
so the answer is yes now that comes in a
lot of forms
if i'm able to successfully like i think
i'm going to
over the next 30 years build a pokemon
like collectible ecosystem well those
characters are going to be a collectible
because they're the first alpha they're
the fossil they're the one and there
will be a collectible value into that
but i'll give you an example i'll give
you another thing that i think about a
lot i think that there's a high chance
that i will open a great adventure
busch gardens you know disney world is a
beast so i don't you know as audacious
as i like to roll with my confidence but
even at disneyland
well
if walt disney started today the way i'm
starting today don't you think that the
original nft holders probably would have
had lifetime passes to disneyland and
disney world because i can tell you
right now i'm putting it on film and
audio we both look young and by the time
i execute this in 30 years we won't look
this good so the split video that i make
then is going to look funny but
every v1
the friends holder will have a lifetime
pass with that to the amusement park and
that's like 26 years from now
value creation
and i will continue to provide value
in how i navigate this even if i
horribly fail in my quest to make people
care about these characters
i can turn these tokens into business
partnerships business mentorships access
to me and a million other things how do
you think uh this leads me to the next
point which is like the the macro view
kind of stepping outside of just nft
specifically and i know you spend um
probably the majority of your time
thinking about nft specifically and how
you can provide value to the people
within your project but if we zoom out
and we just look at crypto do you worry
much about how bitcoin ethereum any of
these other assets are doing on a
day-to-day basis or are you more focused
on kind of just nft landscape and the
rest will take care of itself
more number two
um though i'm a human being and i'm
paying attention
uh
i'm always paying attention obviously in
the filming the time we filmed this
we've had a real
correction drop whatever you want to
call it bearish event since mid-november
early november um
no i don't i don't
get fixated on the short term
there is no scenario where the consumer
blockchain is not a part of our lives in
perpetuity
there's no scenario the cat's out of the
bag they exist
it's over now
yeah i i think i probably agree with
that for sure uh and one of the things
that i give you a lot of credit for uh
both here today and publicly is like
you've been very open and honest about
the risk associated with this stuff
right and i think that uh that's a good
thing because ultimately there is a lot
of risk there's a lot of projects out
there that are not providing any value
really
and people are buying into them for the
exact reasons that you mentioned earlier
that they just want to flip them they're
coming for profit et cetera and you're
going to have that everywhere right i
don't think that means that nfts are
worthless but one of the one of the
questions i got when i tweeted out uh
that we were going to do this was
people were responding and saying hey
look gary has said 98 of these projects
are going to go to zero right they're
worthless and maybe two percent are
really successful and they end up being
worth a lot
what is there is there like an
established criteria in your mind of hey
these are the things that i look for in
a project to make it valuable of those
two percent yeah the only thing i look
for is the founder
it's the only thing i know how to look
at
meaning there'll be tons of things that
are for mark zuckerberg first time
founder
right
like the google guys first time founders
sarah blakely first time like like and
you would have missed those but you're
okay with it yeah
in something this volatile this is so
volatile
that if you're really first of all
a you have to spend money that you can
afford to lose like you have to
like if you're listening right now if
you're investing in nfts it has to be a
sum of money that you can afford to have
to go to zero people playing with their
real life on something this volatile are
in a very vulnerable spot
what i worry about is that people don't
understand the macro in the micro or the
nuance
you could buy 17 projects of nfts all of
those could go from you spending 900
bucks a piece down to 12 bucks
and nfts can still win as a genre it's
called sports cards it's called comic
books
you could have bought
a million dollars worth of comic books
in 1979
and not picked x-men and spider-man and
superman and batman you might have just
decided i'll give you an example i
invested tens of thousands of dollars
when i was 18
into valiant and image comics
all of which have gone down to basically
zero
but had i take spent that same ten
thousand dollars
on
vintage
x-men and spider-man and superman comics
20 years later i would have done well i
picked the wrong comics
i lived that actual life i at one
actually this is a really good one i'm
gonna use this a little bit
i picked the wrong comics
but i was right about comics
i saw back in 1999 that nerd culture
was going to become mainstream culture i
was right i was buying toys and comics
but instead of buying a bunch of toy biz
invisible women and ice fan figures for
80 90 and 100 bucks at shows i should
have been buying you know transformer
gen 1 in package
and that's what i think is happening
right now with nft land people are
buying the newest mint the newest mint
the newest bad the newest influencer
pump
and what you're looking for is the 4 to
5 to 15 to 75 really good projects i
believe the only way you even have a
prayer is to make a judgment call on the
founder how do you think about people
that look at nfts and say i get it but
do i have the time to dig deep in
discord communities do i have the time
to look at every project just walk me
through your thoughts to that person i
say look it's so volatile early now but
you can decide if you want that whether
it's punks or apes or be friends or cool
cats or doodles or world of women it's
all very early but there is a sub group
that is slightly ahead of its peers
and if you really really want to go
there
you know
you can set and forget i'm i'm fairly
set and forget you know one of the
things i've loved about this space is my
my wallets are public people can see my
behaviors now
i'm also
buying certain projects because i want
to support
certain artists i'm buying certain
projects because i do think it's high
risk high reward so i would say there's
a
gambling component to the way i think
about i'm like oh this project i'm not
even sure i like it
but my brain showed me the path
to it being a smash hit
so let me just
set it and forget it
and maybe it's 12
likelihood that it's gonna happen but if
it does happen it's so crazy and if i do
eight of those and one hits it pays for
the other seven and the reason i keep
telling people not to buy what i buy is
i genuinely believe that ninety percent
of the people
are
day trading
they're completely day trading which by
the way
this is a you know the world that most
of the world is got freedom do what you
want with your money i surely can't
set or tell people what to do with their
money
i also think that when you day trade
what i'm fascinated by is these day
traders are mad
at the founders of projects
when their product isn't pumping every
hour on the hour and i tell a lot of
founders i'm like you're listening to
your discord
and your discord is filled with people
that are looking for super duper duper
short
term roi
and you're building a project that you
want to be your project for the rest of
your life
those interests don't align
i don't
i i don't think a lot of people are
navigating their projects properly right
now
because they're playing boy that cries
wolf because they're doing something
every hour on the hour to appease people
in the discord
who are not their community who are
there actually to do their own short
term pump for their own
value and i think that a lot of founders
are going awry
by over listening to people that have
their own financial vested interest in
mine in a very short period of time
versus the founder navigating her or his
project
in perpetuity
yeah i mean you're an investor you get
this more than anyone everyone wants to
be an investor right there's a bunch of
solo uh capitalist everyone wants to go
out and invest money in in these
companies whether private or public or
whatever it is how do you think about
that shift from like should more people
be focusing on the entrepreneurial
aspect of this and building their own
personal brands or should is the
investor route the right way to go i
think self-awareness is the right way to
go
like if like for example a lot of my
friends make fun of me
because i've had such a good investing
career and they're like what are you
like
14 hours a day of meetings with client
what are you doing and i'm like i enjoy
being an operator
and so i think you know i have a lot of
friends who've transitioned and jumped
up and down to both
from operator to investor from investor
to operator
investor operated investor operator
operator investor and they've done the
whole nine and i think i mean there's a
lot of people listening right now should
that should never be either
that should be a number six at a great
company
there's i've talked about this in the
past a lot and i've gotten incredible
emails from people who
sought out a great company calm i
remember somebody sent me an email
they're like you changed my life i was
listening to a podcast i thought i had
to be a founder because it was cool
and you said no just like be self-aware
i was
employed number 13 at com this happened
to me where i was employee number 27 at
this epic cup like
so i i think to answer your question to
get self-awareness like if you genuinely
enjoy investing
and you think you're good at it and it's
enjoyable and it's fulfilling than the
muscle tough for me
i'm very proud that
at the age of 22 may of 1998 to now
january 2022
24 years straight
every day
i have been the sole
pressure on my back to make payroll of a
business all every day and i
successfully built my dad's business
i built one of the largest agencies
independent agencies in the world
i
co-started and sold resi
i co-starred and sold empathy wines
i've got v friends which is which i'm
operating
um i have a lot of pride in being an
actual operator i always
smirk because i've done such a prolific
job with social content and social
content is just like an amuse foosh it's
not a real meal
when people say funny things like what
does garyvee even do
meanwhile i'm doing so many operating
things at once it always makes me laugh
but it means that i've prolifically
shown the public speaker
or the pontificator of ideas on social
um but it's not as obvious that i'm
running a 1500 percent global
agency holding company or that i'm
running a
25 person nft business or
the rezzies and the empathies and the
other things i've done that have been
derivatives of the vayner x
infrastructure and and that and that is
really where i have my pride i'm an
operator
giving up the first 12 years of my
career and i mean really giving it up
seven days a week retail
never getting paid a lot of money
building a business that i left at 34
years old with nothing and no ownership
of
is
disproportionately the greatest
accomplishment of my career
because emotionally
it strikes me on every tear duct i have
in my body i
fundamentally changed the financial
status of my parents
and they're the two people that i most
adore i mean they did everything for me
they immigrated to a new country
my mom is like the ultimate she built
all my emotional graph my dad
worked every hour to make our american
dream come true
it's something that i hope as we end
this podcast that people can really
especially kids that are growing up in a
family business can really take in
because
what i had is all that funny stuff that
people laugh at me about of like you got
time you're young and all the jokes are
like my videos about that i lived it i
was 22
i knew that i was young i knew that i'd
be young at 34
or whenever i left my dad's business
and i didn't have the resentment or the
angst of building it for him and i built
a business from a 3.8 million dollar
business to a 65 million dollar business
which was game-changing for my family
yeah and um and i left happy and
accomplished and i'm a 46 year old man
now 12 years later i feel so grateful
that i did that because
i played out my thesis i built for them
and i have had enough time to build for
myself and now at 46 i have the taste of
both i've been able to do the noble
selfless altruistic
son of a parent group that he loves so
much move that is like i'm extremely
proud of in my soul and i've been able
to do the
accomplish things for myself my selfish
needs the things i need for me and it's
a great [ __ ] feeling
yeah i i really respect and i mean that
was obviously a great answer but i
really respect everything that uh you
your brother your whole family is
building right because i see a lot of
parallels in my life where i get a ton
of enjoyment out of doing things uh with
my family with my brothers with my
parents right and it's like by far and
away the most rewarding part of any of
this is is you know the money doesn't
come with you right so it's uh it's
obviously fun to win but it's funner
it's more fun to do it together it's the
best like dinners laughing
war stories like
it's the best it's the best anyway i'm
overtime i gotta get to something else
this is i appreciate you thank you uh
and uh we'll do it again sometime soon
gary thank you